[Music]
all right so we are in a crazy time
right now and there is a lot of
misinformation out there I think I don't
know I don't read very much about
reading this now and apparently there's
a lot of myths about coronavirus and
here are the tough something that's true
what is your dogs can get it get it
that's a myth isn't it oh no no go tiger
just got it I I pulled up this article
and I read the first few up could be you
know well I heard a tiger a tiger got it
just don't have a pet what I also saw an
article where dogs did have it no
extremes but was a real article then
another one your mom said your mom send
it no she loves me no a friend loaned it
to me I [ __ ] it up it's a myth that's
a myth leave your dogs alone it's a myth
all right the top 10 coronavirus myths
tackled by GP from wearing gloves to
drinking booze all right number one myth
coronavirus is a living organism so the
virus officially named Tsarskoe v2 is
technically not alive it's a fire people
thought the virus is alive well I mean I
thought viruses are like culling they're
technically not alive in a science sense
but like like you can consider them
alive I guess because they can create a
yes but technically they're not alive of
you if you followed by scientific rules
really it says the bacteria live and
viruses are so it's not just for people
that want to kill them so they don't
feel that gal doesn't rule why does it
matter if it's a young MIT that's a
number one myth that I've never even
heard of is its routine
smart person [ __ ] disagreement yeah I
think I'm too stupid to understand them
right number two people are most
contagious before they even know they
have the virus
all the most well that's a Miss before
they even so as soon as you get it
you're the most contagious and then when
you show signs you're not as contagious
its way worse than you caught on people
oh so that's the truth this is untrue
yeah I'm reading the myth oh that's the
myth okay okay cuz it's stupid it's like
oh you're less contagious now that
you're coughing on me then I heard if
you put vapor rub on your chest it goes
away every cultures wakes up wife you
mom's like just drink a sprite it'll go
away yeah I just had to drink bitter
medicine and never go out why people had
that stage but they went past it and it
was called the Victorian era yeah sure
so we're just kind of behind I think so
I'll work backwards we're just catching
up to the science they made smart white
people number three Tsarskoe v2 is a
Hardy virus honey if I get stronger
brain this doctor says the virus is in
fact surprisingly fragile with its only
protection being a thin outer layer of
lipid or fat oh that's why you can wash
your hands and clothes oh yeah that's
right here's soap and detergent you
don't break it down really fast so make
sure to wash constantly oh you know the
earlier myth about the whole like you
can still be contagious
I think what where that came from is the
two-week incubation period because you
can still be contagious without having
symptoms what's different what's
different between the corona and the flu
the flu you can be incubating it could
be incubating with no symptoms for like
a day or two and then you start having
flu-like symptoms
whereas corona you could have two weeks
some cases even 24 days I feel amazed
when people always try to go out on
extremes it's like oh you're not
contagious until you have symptoms and
people are like you can still pass it
when you don't have symptoms and
like oh you could pass away more when
you don't have symptoms it's like okay I
think it's because with eight hours they
don't know they have it so they're still
doing stuff like sharing stuff or like
going on that kind of sense yeah that's
why they keep spreading it but like
obviously when you're able to cough more
that's yeah it comes out bad so depends
on how you look at yeah because now
maybe you're coughing and doing a lot of
stuff that's why it's more spreadable
when you have symptoms that's all true
people do say that young people are the
ones passing it a lot because of the
fact that they often don't show up soon
it'll shut their mouth that too yeah and
they talk too damn much thought they're
sucking too much dick whoa oh he's back
he's back all right number four if a
delivery driver wears gloves they will
not spread it oh well if they're
coughing I think you're gonna believe
that yeah doctor says this is wrong
every item that a gloved hand touches
can't be contaminated duh like if he has
a glove on and he coughs on it and
shakes your hand with it he's passing it
why'd you get food recently and one
person is away and glove and but then
the finger was my person it was from it
was chick-fil-a and I think they were
working so hard that her nails just went
through and I'm like just take them off
there's a picture of this dude waiting
at a checkout and Ifill has a bag of
chips open with gloves and this and the
mask on but he took it off and he's
eating it with a dirty glove dude yeah a
recent study so same same myth about the
delivery drivers right recent study says
the virus can survive for several hours
on cardboard so I forgetting a
deliverable stay saves the best advice
is to not touch the parcel until ideally
the nerve the following day
while the foot thing overall I will give
you a pizza so what date what I've
already supposed to grab it grab it with
gloves transfer the food to something
that doesn't have cardboard and then you
throw away the cardboard or you get it
Oh open it up and then wash your hands
is that we're saying it's all don't
touch the box again yeah yeah open it up
watch your hands and then just only grab
the pizza after oh you're saying the
truth of the mystery I'm saying that's
true that they could pass the virus
stays alive on the cardboard Wow you
ever thought about the food Preppers
just coughing on your food that's why I
hadn't been buying food like the only
time I've been really eating out is here
actually for the lunch j-jake China I
just not yeah try not to think about it
when it's here true you'll never eat
anything at that point
woohoo packaged my meat at the at the
grocery store who who did this who did
that I believe it doesn't live very long
on food we gotta just do what Nadine
said bring the grill cook here and we're
good
oh dear oh god the next one is the virus
cannot be passed on Thai food that's a
myth good this appears to be an area up
for some debate doctors adopt a stricter
approach the risk posed by food than
other experts then why do they keep
fast-food places open I don't know
people can't cook it so you don't have
the means yeah all food is essential
business what have you only order soup
it comes boiling in yeah well they are
couple years ago and they knew your
foreigners right so they're like oh
gonna be extra careful cuz they're
foreigners no people in there they're
like oh you want us to show you how to
eat this thing like how to wrap it
whatever cuz it's like it's like drunk
food so it's not common food and then so
he goes back gets gloves and we're like
oh he's being all clean and fancy he
No he puts the glove on his on his right
hand he grabs chopsticks with his right
hand picks with the food and I don't
think it's the way you think it is it
because he used your chopsticks and he's
giving you're no grandma tropics wrap it
with his bare hand okay I'm in amis dude
what he's probably only we're stupid I'm
seeing all these videos of like we
people pull up to pick up food they have
like like carts in like mekin like
things that they just develop where they
could put things in the basket and slide
it down yeah and they're like delivering
like [ __ ] with drones like they're doing
food delivery not yeah yeah I'm sure
every person is different my guy was
just funny he put in his job as he can
none of it made sense maybe use a really
big fan of Michael Jackson we were just
like don't worry I got this [ __ ]
okay let's do but to answer the whole
food myth took the nature and and
activate the virus food should either be
washed or cooked at 65 degrees Celsius
which I don't know what the Fahrenheit
is don't ask me at least for 4 min
hundred and twenty more about a means
you got to cook your food really really
well I assume to kill the virus I feel
like people from all other countries
they know Fahrenheit and Celsius and we
don't know [ __ ] you know kilometers they
know centimeters I don't know [ __ ]
it's terrible alright number six
sanitizer with 60% alcohol isn't
effective or is as effective as washing
your hands and soap and water that is a
myth Wow
I think we learned that like a little
bit early on
I didn't know that okay cool oh no you
know now I feel like I wouldn't say cuz
anyone was like hoarding all the hand
sanitizer yeah and everyone was like oh
you can use alcohol they'll take like a
bottle of alcohol and it'll mix that and
they'll start wiping their hands with it
because they couldn't get hand sanitizer
and they were like oh it needs to be
like 70% or more yeah oh yeah because
alcohol is usually 40% only moonshine
shine yeah number seven drinking alcohol
will prevent people from getting the
virus false alcohol going into those at
all that'd be 70% alcohol then I think
you would die I don't know there's no
winning in this article I don't know
what Everclear it's like that much it's
a goofy Everclear yeah every play is
like 75%
it's like 140 uh proof I think 148 or
some like that baby yeah and then
Bacardi you liccardi 140 you want 121 oh
my god 76% alcohol so I had a friend who
drank every clear he took like one shot
and then he I think he blacked out
because then he's just started like like
rolling around in the grass in the
backyard and then like there was like a
construction area and his backyard or in
this particular it was a house party I
don't even know whose house it was
there's like they were fixing some stuff
and then like he just kinda like fell
over and then fell on a break brick
print yeah it was just like a clear like
the brick print yeah
number eight moisturizing hands after
washing reduces cleanliness what
moisturizing hands I didn't think that
reduce this click it just [ __ ]
moisturizes your hands oh yeah I put in
motion yeah protective maybe they're
like oh the myth is that it reduces
cleanliness maybe they're like oh the
lotion makes me sticky everybody virus
so he said reduces clinic
hands after washing reduces clowning I
just thought it makes your skin smoother
I'm pretty sure that's finish off the
list real quick
number 9 washing hands is not as
important when Iced oneself isolating as
you are all as you are all virus free
okay true that's false oh come on
so wash your hands even if you're by
yourself and number 10 vinegar is good
for keeping bathrooms and kitchens free
of the virus true you said this earlier
I did yeah you said something about
vinegar like [ __ ] vinegar or whatever
I'm like true that's true
that's possible Gio I think I think
we've been confused by this whole myth
is true or false you know true true Oh
actually I should actually know menthol
is a true truth
what you said true true to him but I
don't know if that's really true or
false all softballs the way you should
have read it it should have just been
like a test and then we just find out
that we're all dumbasses and they're all
false true yeah
[Music]